Welcome to "American Talk," the only talk show devoted to teaching strange foreigners...
...how to speak the right way, the American way.
My guests today, Daniel Radcliffe and the cast of Harry Potter.
Awesome.
Emma, I'm gonna give you a few phrases and I wanna hear your best.
Okay.
US, American.
I'm really feeling the pressure.
I feel like this is an audition or something. Okay, go.
The olive garden.
The what?
Do I have to say this one? Glenn Beck.
Glenn, Glenn Beck.
Charlie Sheen.
Glenn Beck.
What? Why do you got Glenn Beck and Charlie Sheen on the same list?
That's what Americans say.
Okay!
Booyah.
Do you really say "booyah"?
I do. That's an American statement.
Really? Okay. All right, I'm going to learn that one.
Booyah.
What the hell are these places? Are they restaurants?
Hey buddy, can I get an order of mozzarella sticks please?
Hey buddy, can I get an order of?
Hey buddy. Man, can I get an order of mozzarella sticks please?
Sold. You're hired.
Yeah.
Two more.
You'd hire me?
Justin Bieber is the man.
Oh man! Justin Bieber, he is the man. Booyah!
My apologies in advance, Rob.
I'm just reading what's on the card.
I'm just following orders.
"Twilight" blows.
Oh, this is controversial.
This is a trick!
You are trying to trick me!
"Twilight" blows.
So, what language do you speak?
I speak American.
You speak American? For some reason, I thought it was English.
No, no, no. It's the freedom language.